>>> THOTHER BIG POLITICAL NEWS
TONIGHT, PRESIDENT BEN SIGNING
A SWEEPING THREE QUARTER OF A
TRILLION SPENDING BILL ON HEALTH
AND CLIMATE, WHAT PRESIDENT
OBAMA IS CALLING BFD WHICH IS A
NOD TO THE HOT MIC MOMENT OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
THE BILL BIDEN SIGNED EARLIER
WILL EXTEND OBAMACARE SUBSIDIES
FOR ANOTHER THREE YEARS AND
ALLOW MEDICARE TO NEGOTIATE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES FOR THE
FIRST TIME, CUT GREENHOUSE
EMISSIONS AND INSTITUTE A 15%
MINIMUM CORPORATE TAX.
THIS IS A BIG POLITICAL MOMENT
FOR BIDEN AND HE IS SEIZING THE
MOMENT.
>> TODAY OFFERS FURTHER PROOF
THAT THE SOUL OF AMERICA IS
VIBRANT, THE FUTURE OF AMERICA
IS BRIGHT AND THE PROMISE OF
AMERICA IS REAL AND JUST
BEGINNING.
>> TRYING TO SEIZE THAT MOMENT,
THERE WAS THE SO-CALLED CHIPS,
THE SEMICONDUCTOR BILL THAT
PASSED.
ALL THIS IS AHEAD OF THE
MIDTERMS.
NIA, BEFORE BIDEN GOT THIS BILL
THROUGH, THIS IS THE MODIFIED
BUILD BACK BETTER THAT THEY CALL
THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT,
THOUGH ECONOMISTS BEG TO DIFFER
ON THAT, CERTAINLY IN THE SHORT
TERM.
A CNN POLL SHOWED 75% OF
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS WANTED SOMEONE
ELSE TO BE THEIR NOMINEE IN
2024.
75%, THAT'S TERRIBLE IF YOU'RE
THE POTENTIAL NOMINEE.
DOES THIS BILL IMPACT HIS
PROMISE IN HIS OWN PARTY?
>> I THINK IT DOES.
TWO SEPARATE ISSUES.
ONE BEING 2022, ONE BEING 2024.
THE THROUGH LINE BEING HOW
DEMOCRATS FEEL ABOUT HIM.
ONE OF THE REASONS HIS APPROVAL
RATINGS ARE BELOW WHERE TRUMP'S
WERE BACK IN THE DAY, WHERE
OBAMA'S WERE BACK IN THE DAY IS
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS DON'T SUPPORT
HIM AT THE SAME RATE.
I THINK 70, 80%.
DEMOCRATS ARE LIKE WHAT'S THE
POINT OF THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY IF
THEY CAN'T ACTUALLY GET ANYTHING
DONE.
THEY DID DELIVER ON KEY ISSUES
THAT DEMOCRATS CARE ABOUT,
AROUND CLIMATE CHANGE, YOUNG
VOTERS PARTICULARLY CARE ABOUT
THAT.
HEALTH CARE, VETERANS, AND THE
GUN SAFETY BILL.
THESE ARE REAL DELIVERABLES.
THEY WON'T NECESSARILY BE FELT
IMMEDIATELY BY AMERICANS, BUT I
THINK DEMOCRATS WHO ARE SO DOWN
IN THE DUMPS A MONTH AGO IN
TERMS OF PROSPECTS IN 2022 AND
DOWN ON BIDEN GENERALLY, THEY
SEE NOW A PRESIDENT AND A PARTY
THAT'S ABLE TO GET SOMETHING
DONE.
>> CHRIS, THE REPUBLICANS
COUNTED THIS AS A SURE THING.
HOW MANY TIMES DO YOU HEAR
THREATS COMING FROM THE LIKES OF
JIM JORDAN ABOUT WHEN THEY'RE IN
CHARGE OF COMMITTEES WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO.
DOES ANY OF THIS CHANGE THE
MIDTERMS?
REPUBLICANS THINKING THEY HAD A
SURE THING?
>> I THINK IT HELPS ON THE
MARGINS.
I DON'T THINK A LOT.
I DON'T THINK REAL PEOPLE SIT
THERE AND GO JOE BIDEN SIGNED
FOUR BILLS AND THAT'S VERY GOOD.
IT'S HOW THEY EXPERIENCE THEIR
LIVES.
FIRST OF ALL, ON THE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICING,
MEDICARE BEING ABLE TO NEGOTIATE
PRICES, THAT DOESN'T KICK IN
UNTIL 2026.
IT DOESN'T KICK IN, NOT ONLY NOT
BEFORE THIS ELECTION, IT DOESN'T
KICK IN BEFORE THE NEXT
ELECTION.
IT'S ONLY TEN DRUGS.
THE $2,000 CAP DOESN'T QUICK IN
UNTIL 2025.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO EXPERIENCE
BETWEEN NOW AND NOVEMBER?
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO EXPERIENCE
LOWER DRUG PRICES.
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE HIGH GAS PRICES,
LOWER THAN A MONTH AGO.
I'M VERY EXCITED, $3.89, I'M
SITTING THERE GOING, I'M SAVING
MONEY.
GROCERIES ARE UP.
DO I THINK IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
DRAMATIC IMPACT?
WHAT MAY HAVE A DRAMATIC IMPACT,
TRUMP, THE FACT THAT HE'S BACK,
HE'S THE HEADLINE AND TO THE
DEGREE THE DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING
ABOUT TRUMP AND FOCUSING ON
TRUMP, NOT BIDEN, I THINK IT'S
GOOD FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
CONVERSELY, I THINK WHEN
REPUBLICANS ARE ABLE TO FOCUS ON
BIDEN AND NOT TRUMP, IT'S GOOD
FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
THE NEWS CYCLE RIGHT NOW IS VERY
MUCH PRO DEMOCRAT.
>> DAVID, WHAT ABOUT THIS?
TRUMP RIGHT NOW IS LOOKING AT
THIS AND ALL HIS LEGAL ISSUES,
AND IT SEEMS TO BE JUST A MATTER
OF WHEN.
NOT IF, BUT WHEN.
>> THOSE ARE HIS VERY WORDS.
>> HOW DOES THAT IMPACT THIS, IF
HE JUMPS IN BEFORE THE NOVEMBER
ELECTIONS?
>> THE PEOPLE THAT AGREE WITH
CHRIS IAN ANALYSIS JUST NOW ARE
THE PEOPLE RUNNING THE
REPUBLICAN CAMPAIGN.
THEY THINK IF TRUMP IS FRONT AND
CENTER AND HE ANNOUNCES PRE
MIDTERM ELECTION DAY, THAT'S NOT
GOOD FOR THEM.
THAT THAT TAKES THE ATTENTION
AND FOCUS OFF THE ECONOMY,
INFLATION, BIDEN.
>> THEN BECOMES A REFERENDUM ON
TRUMP.
>> EXACTLY.
TRUMP WILL SUCK UP ALL THE
OXYGEN.
LET'S BE CLEAR, THAT WILL ALSO